il y assez pelouse son campus il ya le
tram bien sûr mais le principal atout de
l'université de bourgogne
c'est justement sa localisation je me
sens bacall cette année donc j'ai mis
fac de droit et voilà j'ai pas mis notre
fac parce que pour rester chez moi
travailler c'est plus simple que si
j'allais ailleurs j'aurais dû prendre un
appart et j'aurais pas réussi à faire la
part des choses travaillées et sortir
trente mille étudiants aujourd'hui et
presque autant de voeux formulés sur
parcours sup 19e fête la plus demandée
de france l'ubs et progresse dans les
classements internationaux meilleure
communication sur les publications
scientifiques en service après vente
efficace dans le domaine des sciences de
l'alignement et de l'alimentation
on est deuxième en france et on est dans
les 150 meilleures universités au monde
et dans le domaine des sciences du sport
on est également second en france et
dans les 100 meilleurs sites
universitaires au bond et ça c'est
clairement l'excellence de notre
recherche dans leur immense majorité les
étudiants sont bourguignon franc comtois
parfois mais les pépites
ce sont les étrangers pour lui les
besoins le crime généré moi je suis
ingénieur en électronique
j'aime ce travail et sur les processeurs
sur ce qu'on appelle les réseaux
logiques programmables
ça m'a vraiment plu la médecine le droit
ou intimité sur 38 filière 17 sont déjà
presque plein la fac attire les
premières années mais c'est elle comment
les garder pour moi c'est un choix
logique
c'était trop mal tenir ici et après fur
et à mesure de sa liberté pour moi il
n'y avait aucune raison d'aller cueillir
sa jambe le masters était très mauvaise
6000 places seulement cette année quatre
dossiers sur cinq finiront forcément
rocade